Захід шокований словами і діями Володимира Путіна щодо України.
Визнання Москвою так званих "ДНР" і "ЛНР" і розпорядження російського президента ввести війська РФ
на підконтрольні сепаратистам території на Донбасі викликали нерозуміння і обурення.
Почалося все із позачергового засідання Ради безпеки РФ,
члени якого буцімто "переконували" Путіна визнати незалежність самопроголошених "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
Прокремлівські російські ЗМІ повідомляли, що про це їх попрохали так звані глави цих самопроголошених "республік".
Тим часом у соцмережах багато хто вказує на те, що заявлена трансляція в ефірі була насправді не наживо, а у записі.
Визнання Росією так званих "ДНР" і "ЛНР" на Донбасі
порушує суверенітет і територіальну цілісність України,
заявила в ніч на вівторок заступниця генерального секретаря ООН Розмарі Дікарло
на екстреному засіданні Ради Безпеки ООН, присвяченому російсько-українському конфлікту.
Тим самим Путін розірвав мінські угоди на шматки, зауважила постійна представниця США при ООН.
Президент Путін виступив із промовою, у якій чітко сформулював привід для вторгнення.
При цьому він розірвав мінські угоди на шматки і, як сказав сьогодні генеральний секретар, порушив статут ООН.
Щойно мій російський колега зробив бездоказові заяви, які свідчать про зусилля щодо створення приводу для конфлікту.
І це вкрай тривожно, показово та ганебно.
Представниця США при ООН також заявила про те, що на цьому тлі
запровадження нових санкцій з боку Вашингтона проти Росії стало неминучим.
Про санкції заявив і британський прем'єр.
Ми негайно введемо пакет економічних санкцій, на які, я думаю, люди очікують,
спрямованих не лише проти суб'єктів на Донбасі - Луганська та Донецька -
а й самої Росії, спрямованих проти російських економічних інтересів настільки сильно, наскільки це взагалі можливо...
Мушу підкреслити, що це лише перша лавина економічних санкцій Великобританії проти Росії,
бо, боюся, попереду на нас чекає ще більше ірраціональної поведінки Росії.
Сумно те, що з кожним витком цієї кризи песимістичні прогнози Великобританії дедалі більше підтверджуються.
Офіційний Берлін відреагував на останні новини з Росії через 12 годин.
Німецький уряд зупиняє сертифікацію газопроводу "Північний потік-2" на невизначений термін.
Про це заявив особисто канцлер ФРН Олаф Шольц,
який тривалий час виступав за введення газопроводу в експлуатацію.
Ситуація сьогодні докорінно інша.
І тому ми змушені з огляду на останній розвиток подій цю ситуацію по-новому оцінювати,
зокрема і щодо "Північного потоку-2".
Я попросив сьогодні федеральне міністерство економіки відкликати існуючу аналітику
щодо безпеки енергопостачання, подану на розгляд Федеральному мережевому агентству.
Це звучить дещо технічно, але це є необхідним адміністративним кроком,
аби наразі сертифікація газогону не могла відбутися.
А без цієї сертифікації "Північний потік-2" неможливо запустити в експлуатацію.
Загалом у столиці Німеччини монолог президента Росії про Україну
викликав серед фахівців зі Східної Європи ефект, близький до стану шоку.
Експерти налаштовані песимістично і кажуть про ризики, що зростають, не тільки для України, а й усієї Європи.
Путін не намагається нас обдурити, а справді вірить у те, що він - історична постать,
і він інтерпретує історію в дусі, що нагадує 20-30-ті роки минулого століття.
Перед нами Путін, який живе абсолютно власною реальністю, і це дуже небезпечно.
І те, що ми почули у промові поняття "геноцид", яке він ужив, означає в принципі, що Росія може все.
Все можливо, будь-які варіанти можливі щодо України.
Експерти вважають, що у Кремлі бояться не НАТО чи ракет,
а вимог громадянських свобод та демократизації російського суспільства.
По суті, ми маємо справу з групою літніх чоловіків, хоч і не зовсім у віці Брежнєва,
але вже старші за 70 або майже 70, які, скажімо так, самоізолювалися від страху перед тим,
що могло би прийти із Заходу.
І це не військова загроза, а ідея демократії, самовизначення та участі суспільства.
Німецькі експерти одностайно наголошують: жорсткі заходи у відповідь вкрай важливі.
Реакція Заходу має бути цього разу однозначною!
Звісно, цілком можливо, що Путін вже виносив усі свої плани і не зупиниться перед жодними санкціями.
Але в даний момент санкції - практично єдиний спосіб для тих, хто не хоче використовувати військову силу.
Бо це був би дуже небезпечний шлях, на який у НАТО поки ніхто ставати не готовий.
Прогнози на майбутнє - невтішні.
Німецькі політологи кажуть, що у військовому плані протиставити Росії нічого
і що їх дуже непокоїть доля України.
Мені здається, що багато хто на Заході так досі і не зрозумів, що, власне, відбувається.
Вони жодним чином не готові до цих жорстких військових дій та ігнорування всіх, у тому числі міжнародних законів.
І вони не готові - ні європейці, ні американці - адекватно реагувати.
Ні ментально, ні санкціями, ні військовою силою.
Робити прогнози щодо того, наскільки далеко може зайти конфлікт, ніхто з експертів не береться.